pilot the bombuh death pilot to
bombardier
w WK WK + Z the Dutch station
just like that it's Monday [ __ ]
April 25th today the devil was buried at
sea and there you are sitting there
where you ask oh I'm fine I'm saying to
beautiful day to be alive the sun
shining the berry to share you woke up
in a [ __ ] hard dick and a battle
[ __ ] eminem who's better than you
uncle Joey here you're thinking to
yourself jug where the [ __ ] you've been
through for this it was a muffle all
right up in my room I can't be blowing
[ __ ] porches besides I need to give
the [ __ ] periscope a couple days you
[ __ ] miss Yun chol Joey and
know what you got till you're losing
[ __ ] my essay I'm [ __ ] stoned
to the gills of them rocking this
[ __ ] since 7am 6am smoke and
writin drink your [ __ ] smoothies I
don't give a [ __ ] but enough is enough
humble joy what's with the
chitter-chatter either spark that
[ __ ] let me go back to work
we've got a beautiful conglomeration of
reefers tonight we got perennials best
Paris og forgot about it you smoked that
you guys shootin had my [ __ ] jihad
and we got this [ __ ] oh exclusive
look at the tail end for this
[ __ ] from sunset herb beautiful
weekend mouthful I want me give a shout
out to the club the [ __ ] food the
people you people [ __ ] phenomena I
love you Buffalo so it wasn't nine
[ __ ] penguins up there I'd be up
there walking around with a bikini given
our [ __ ] loose joints but [ __ ] don't
work out that way Joey what's with the
chitter-chatter spark that [ __ ]
say no more goodness I'm slipping
another stem get in there what the [ __ ]
is wrong with him a professional yawns
I'm
zip baby says it is Monday you got
another whole bag you write your goals
you polished that [ __ ] pink helmet
and you go out there like you [ __ ] on
it even if you don't think you're good
on it you [ __ ] on him I'm saying I
don't give a [ __ ] you're walking there
you look em in the eye you put that dick
on the table and say now what [ __ ]
I gotcha everyone don't make no longer
smoking enjoy my dad a little drill
class I got a meeting I got the death of
my nose doctor and I got a podcast at
eight tremendous [ __ ] podcast and I'd
be there or be square Joey spark
when the rocket ship explodes every
money right man said happy too man truly
die oh my oh why why sign of the times
boom boom boom Oh something awful Prince
pretty under well we all gotta [ __ ]
go sometime I saw that [ __ ] the
summer of 84 had to [ __ ] me all those
clubs are rich for some $15 million
digital Aloha brenham to see jam on it
[ __ ] Sheba even Prince man at least I
got to see him I was very [ __ ]
fortunate what are you gonna do I saw
him in [ __ ] 93 at the Radio City
[ __ ] tremendous my heart goes out to
his family though his [ __ ] fans out
there would be dwelling touch enzyme and
then we're [ __ ] the boy you to do is
put on a purple shirt one thing that you
dicks up that's it that's all I respect
the Prince get a [ __ ] purple shirt on
polish that [ __ ] star media and go
out there and spread some [ __ ] love
you Sam when tricky nicky whatever the
[ __ ] thing
anyway enough with the sentimental [ __ ]
heads back to [ __ ] mondays and
smoking reefer of what you need to do my
[ __ ] okay you know what you need to do
don't sit down look at me like I'm a
[ __ ] move from the other side you put
on a shirt shine your shoes brush your
teeth and get out there and tell these
[ __ ] you know what I'm here I
work for free for a [ __ ] week and I
work all you [ __ ] here just an
instant you know saying that's how I
thought the world the skewer debt on
Monday morning you rate that custom
another [ __ ] good little buddy though
your life that's so [ __ ] important
let's finish this [ __ ] for starters
right no [ __ ] half containers here
especially on a Monday to bring your
[ __ ] bad luck oh yeah oh yes oh there
you are it's my day about my day is
about happiness today just to be [ __ ]
happy today that's it some people might
about their win some people wanted a lot
of [ __ ] tie some people after to
impress other [ __ ] like look at
me with my new tattoo of a [ __ ] sold
you listen you know my tattoo of a
soldier is and my [ __ ] nut sack okay
and I'm my [ __ ] on I got a
bulletproof [ __ ] machine gun that's
all you need to [ __ ] though right I
don't need a pat tool to show you what
the [ __ ] I'm thinkin it's in my [ __ ]
nut sack that's what I'm [ __ ]
thinking [ __ ] so get your [ __ ]
together it's Monday ain't nobody givin
you dick today understanding
like a lunch Mitch pack a lunch they had
donate the marine siempre free I'm
saying and that's it a ruling about
Seattle upon an appeal hoy from our
amazing i wrote a good day toll on but
there are meeting a rope and good but I
said I won't hesitate or a quarter
morongo a very true Belleza rickenbach
casino and waste our time that underpin
Impala Lenya Lenya Rick our hero no team
etro pasaron por aya by esta la pasaron
call overhead also then said American
area way you're gonna be a [ __ ]
mentally forget about your feelings and
huh however he was politically and cool
gives a [ __ ] there's people out there
getting stabbed and your [ __ ] getting
your feelings hurt because of some white
kids said about some [ __ ] Chinese kid
playing with a [ __ ] for his now give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's Monday smoke
that reefer how your cat and get out
there good just my prince you don't know
when God's gonna shut the fire my job
okay so [ __ ] you and [ __ ] your plastic
other you're a better you hit today by
the [ __ ] okay and that's it I smoke
they're not bothering your mother [ __ ]
I'm stoned to the gills
and that's it that's all a man is humble
Joey away